bring in ron vitiello he is the former
acting ice director under president
trump and former chief of the border
patrol in the obama administration ron
it's always good to see you i want to
put up some of these headlines because
even the liberal media
will kind of hit kamala harris for her
trip down there cnn
harris plays it safe at u.s mexico
border and releases pressure valve
new york times touring the border harris
asked questions and had few answers
npr's saying harris visits the southern
border after trying to keep the focus
away from it and kind of picking up on
alex hogan's reporting there
are you surprised that the vice
president did not go to the epicenter
the rio grande valley
not surprised more disappointed right
the problem that exists on the border
there's a surge
all across the southwest border but that
surge is most acute
in the rio grande valley that's where
the challenge is the
greatest uh for the men and women of dhs
specifically the border patrol so yes
i'm disappointed that she didn't go
where the the problem exists
in its in its biggest form and and what
i'm also disappointed in is like
there isn't any solutions offered in her
interactions with the media
uh or that we were that were reported
out on on her visit in el paso
yeah you know where how are they going
to restore order to that border how are
they going to reduce the chaos
and the misery that your rep your
reporter is talking about in places like
falfurious
where thousands of people are trying to
make it past the border patrol
because they know now is the time to
come in because the policies that were
keeping
that surge at bay in 2019 uh have been
taken off the table and so
here's here's where we are she can check
the box
she visited the border but no solutions
no augmentation no increased border
security interest
it's interesting sir that you talk about
solutions because she also talked about
that when she was down there and i want
to get your take
after you hear this sound bite listen
we can take all of these
perspectives into account and have
meaningful good public policy
if we just stop the rhetoric you can't
just
react to a problem without solving it
at its roots let's agree to that
so you can't react to the actual problem
we have tent cities at the border we
have people that are going through the
fence day by day by the thousands and
she's talking about the root causes
in the in the northern triangle right
guatemala honduras honduras el salvador
that's 10 years down the road the answer
the question is what happens right now
right don't believe your own eyes there
are thousands of people surging at the
border across the
the u.s mexico border but we're going to
work on what exactly
what are the solutions what are the
implementations that's going to
keep this surge from continuing there
are over a million apprehensions so far
this year and we're
we're only in june july yeah
and i want to play this because this is
the national sheriff's association
president
saying this is also what the vice
president should have focused on listen
she also should have visited the
residence
along the border the ranchers the people
living in the cities that are
that are now being terrorized by some of
the criminal elements that are coming
across
as well every day they are being
terrorized along the border your final
yeah thoughts cartels are benefiting
here and the the people who are
suffering are some of the migrants that
are in this pipeline
and the people have to live on the
border and see this traffic uh you
showed doc vickers earlier you know his
his land
inundated with people trying to walk
around the checkpoint there it fell
furious that's what happens when you
have a chaotic border
that's what happens when you pull down
policies that are working and
and here we are we're still waiting for
solutions
director vitiello always good to hear
you sir thank you
thank you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary
any great news bites any great
interviews coming your way on fox you
can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now